now we looked at these yesterday and in
you know the past week or so not to
mention the rest of the course so today
I said I'm promising more so we're going
to go from straight lines to parabolas
to actually all in one hit we're gonna
use technology to help us three other
kinds of graphs okay the first one is
see how we've got power one for this guy
power 2 for this guy what do you think
is the next logical step 3 so um here's
the first one the second one here's the
third one
[Applause]
ok now you might notice as you increase
in power your terms or your ex equations
get more and more complicated and messy
ok
that's because you can have more
different terms inside here if you go
all the way up to 3x cubed you can have
X Squared's and in X's and constant
numbers at the end so this is something
really complicated but you often get
much simpler versions than this or if
you go a messy one we can use some
technology to muck around with this ok
so I've been doing examples in orange so
let's have a look for instance and we'll
start with something simple the simplest
possible one actually is just y equals x
cubed which is why this is not quite a
straight line or probably it's called a
cubic curve so I'm desmos go ahead and
get rid of all of this stuff now in
order to get on the power of three or
desmos you'll need to tap this button
here which says a to the power of B
because then you can pick any power you
like because there's no one there's the
cubed button here automatically so hit
that you can see my cursor is up the top
now and I'm going to hit 3 there we go
so here's our cubic curve it bears some
similarities to a parabola which we've
looked at before
what kind of similarities can you see
great so it fits our definition it's not
linear that's good
do you notice this part over here if you
just hid in fact I am gonna hide if you
hide the where's what I want it's here
you didn't have to worry about what I'm
doing now I just want to show you this
part if I just hit the left hand side of
the graph and you didn't know what this
graph was if you just saw the picture
that looks a whole white like a parabola
doesn't it right and that should make
sense because it's kind of in the same
family of equations and functions but
it's not if I go ahead and I bring it
back and put x squared in the picture
let's put y equal x squared you can see
while they've got similar kinds of
shapes how would you describe the blue
graph in comparison to the green one the
blue graph in comparison to the green
one yeah the blue one well it's funny
but the one is steeper for most of it in
fact if I keep on going and going and
going and going the blue one is always
steeper than the green one
except for this tiny little patch right
here do you see that little spot there
it's just underneath I'll let you have a
think about why that is the case it's
not so important right now I just want
you to notice that it is there's the
other difference of course it's not just
that it's steeper if I get rid of this
bit when you see the whole thing the
other glaring difference is this guy
down here right it goes down to the
negatives why does it do that this
parabola doesn't but the cubic one does
why doesn't the problem ever come down
why does it go straight back up this is
but wait but it's doing the opposite of
that isn't it I want you to think back
now here's where the table of values is
so instructive for us ah okay so think
about the values that you were putting
here
for instance if actually equal to
negative one here's my x-axis here's my
y-axis if X is equal to negative one
then Y is negative one times negative
one but look there's two negatives which
cancel and give you positive one is it
does that make sense if I try over here
x equals negative 2 then Y will equal
negative 2 times negative 2 and there's
two negatives against so they cancel and
they give you 4 okay but the cubic has
no such problem because when you cube
negative numbers they stay negative does
that make sense so all your negative X
values also give you negative Y values
can I let you take a minute to draw this
please so y equals x cubed is the one
we're focusing on right now and it's
quite a it grows really fast as if we
pointed out its steeper than x squared
so these numbers up here get very big
very quickly so adjust the scale of your
graph appropriately if for instance you
wanted to go all the way to x equals 3
which actually is not that far what is y
equal if X is equal to 3 y is going to
be 3 that's gonna be 27 isn't it
so you're gonna have to go up pretty
high in fact that's why mine is not on
there so I'm gonna try and fix that
there we go tada so you can see there's
x equals 3 it goes all up to 27 so I'll
give you a couple of minutes now to draw
yourself up a set of axes you're gonna
need the whole lot there and choose an
appropriate scale I think if you went
over to x equals 3 then y equals 30 is a
nice round number to stop at up there
but also don't forget if you go to
positive 30 have a look on this side I
need to zoom out you're probably gonna
want to come down to negative 30 as well
so this is gonna be a big vertical scale
and not so much horizontally can you
draw that for me try and get a nice
smooth curve okay um
could you get your calculator out for me
if you haven't got it already now what
we're going to try out is this
particular graph here this one this
equation we're going to test out some
values okay now when we test this out
we're going to notice something unusual
so let's see what happens when we try at
x equals negative 1 you can go to your
calculator just be watchful with your
brackets though because if you want to
do negative 1 cubed typing in this to
your calculator is not the same as that
what you really want to type is that
okay you've got to be quite watchful
with your brackets because otherwise
it's not applying the negative sign it's
not cubing the kitten to the negative
sign which is kind of important so the
way you would punch this into your
calculator would be like so that's the
way I would actually that's what should
be on your calculator display and you're
gonna get a number out of this I think
this is gonna be negative 1 and this bit
here will be minus 4 so I predict that
this will give you negative 5 can I get
some confirmation yep happy times so
I've got a y-value that's good you don't
even need your calculator to work out
the next value because look it's x
equals 0 so just have a look don't don't
calculate anything just look at it what
will happen to this when x is 0 it's
just gone what about this guy also gone
so you just get 0 okay I'm go ahead work
out 1 & 2 for me I'll give you some time
to catch up and we're going to draw this
so you might want to start to put
together a set of axes just like this
use a different one don't do it on the
same one as the one you just drew
because it's going to get messy okay um
can you tell me what Y values do you get
out of these guys can someone tell me
negative 3 and negative 8 is that right
okay now you've got a set of axes there
but something weird is going on because
these four points which I can read off
here they don't seem to match what I was
expecting
cuz have a look I want you to go ahead
and plot these negative 1 negative 5
this is 0 0 this is 1 negative 3 and
this is 2 negative 8 ok now I'm going to
start to plot these myself
so fine where they belong
okay now we don't have the whole shape
just yet we're trying to discover what's
going on by plotting points but we get
this which is weird if this is all
you've got
and we know what kinds of shapes we're
familiar with what does it look like
it's tracing out right now what does it
look like it's tracing out it sure looks
like it's doing this parabola thing
right except for the fact that we know
there's a q2 there this is a cubic so it
shouldn't be tracing out a parabola what
that indicates to us is these values so
we've got at the moment it's not enough
it's not enough this part of it looks
like a parabola but that must mean we
don't have the whole picture so here's
what I'm gonna ask you to do last time
when we were experimenting we went 1 2 3
4 5 I think we don't need to go quite
that far but we are going to need 2 more
values on the end here so maybe with the
person next to you one of you can work
at three one of you can work out four
find out what they are and then plot
them can you do that for me
[Applause]
has anyone got a value for three yet
minus nine and the value for four should
be zero have you got it she get zero
which shouldn't surprise you by the way
because look four cubed and then here is
four times four times four which is four
cubes so we can put these guys on as
well three comma negative 9 and 4 comma
zero
let's plot those on as well
okay so what have we just revealed well
even by the time we get to this green
one here I might get rid of the orange
one even by the time we get to here you
can already see this is got a parabola
right like a parabola if it really was
would come up it would go down and then
what does it do after this it just gets
steeper and steeper and steeper but look
this guy is kind of like whoa slow down
it kind of seems to come back up with
and there by the tiny part on this last
point 4 comma 0 you know you've got
something completely different you have
this kind of wavy sort of shape okay so
you can connect these dots and lo and
behold you should get this shape in
total there we go so this is a cubic
just like before except it's just it
waves around a little bit before it does
the same thing as this you can see the
negative values down here you go all the
way down the positive values go all the
way up so this just like our previous
one is another member of the cubic
family okay so same kind of shape but
plotting the points gives us the exact
kind of details of what's happening does
that make sense